i
[Música]
ah
el mandatario de venezuela nicolás
maduro ha señalado en varias ocasiones
su disposición de dialogar con el
presidente electo de eeuu las relaciones
diplomáticas entre ambos países
atraviesan su peor momento luego de que
washington ha negado la legalidad del
gobierno de maduro e impuesto sanciones
por vulnerar la democracia eeuu no
quiere diálogo y responsabiliza al
gobierno socialista de la debacle
económica en venezuela y de violaciones
a derechos humanos maduro ha insistido
en que el país norteamericano tiene un
salvaje bloqueo a la economía venezolana
y ha pedido a sus seguidores estar de
pie y preparados para lo que haya que
hacer en fin de defender a venezuela del
imperio
washington lidera la presión
internacional contra maduro a quien
tilda de dictador para ello ha emitido
una serie de sanciones que intentan
forzar su salida pues consideran que la
reelección para su segundo mandato en
mayo de 2018 fue fraudulenta además
presentó cargos en la justicia contra
maduro por narcoterrorismo y ofrece una
recompensa de hasta 15 millones de
dólares por su captura
[Música]
la versión oficial del régimen iraní es
que las elecciones norteamericanas no
son tan importantes y mucho menos quien
sea el ganador ellos creen y aseguran
que esto no cambiará la posición de eeuu
en contra de irán pero otra realidad es
la que se oye en la calle y se lee en
los medios de comunicación donde si se
habla de que quien gane marque una
diferencia a los nadies también han
hablado en los últimos días de la
acusación del fbi de hackers iraníes
queriendo intervenir en las elecciones
norteamericanas lo que aquí se niega en
irán sin embargo si se habla de que el
sentimiento ante a norteamérica anti
norteamericano nunca había sido tan
grande en este país por varias políticas
del presidente de donald trump
una de ellas retirar a eeuu del acuerdo
nuclear e imponer nuevas sanciones lo
que ha hecho la vida a los iraníes está
aún más difícil y también el asesinato
del general de las fuerzas qods iraníes
castle suleimán y el pasado enero
[Música]
el que el vino ha dicho que consideran
lamentables las declaraciones de eeuu
sobre la presunta injerencia de rusia en
las elecciones estadounidenses de 2020
el portavoz de la presidencia rusa
dmitri peskov ha lamentado que las
acusaciones contra rusia se lancen cada
día y a todas horas de una manera
absolutamente infundada se refería a las
acusaciones del director de inteligencia
nacional de eeuu que dijo en una rueda
de prensa que irán y rusia obtuvieron
datos sobre los votantes estadounidenses
rusia ha reiterado en varias ocasiones
que las acusaciones de intentos de
influir en los procesos democráticos de
otros países no tienen ningún tipo de
fundamento aunque es cierto también que
moscú lleva años acusando a estados
unidos de estar detrás de las
manifestaciones de la oposición liberal
en rusia en concreto la principal
sospechosa era hillary clinton la gran
perdedora de aquellas polémicas
elecciones de 2016
[Música]